I'm in Helsing book in Sweden to fill a
museum and normally I don't travel just
to film museums because most museums
science Natural History are pretty much
the same the world over but this museum
is not only interesting it's also unique
welcome to the Museum of Paleontology
sale so everybody in the business knows
this and where are these failures
companies sweep them under the carpet
and pretend they don't exist the museum
of failure takes these failed products
put some on display so that everybody
can learn from them
The Criterion product has to meet to be
here is that it was an innovation and
that it was a failure and the failure is
a deviation from expected and desired
outcome I didn't know so even how to
getting there
this is there a sort of hidden dark
secret this one was supposed to measure
the EEG of the dog's brain and then
translate those mental states into human
voice of course utter nonsense it's
completely impossible I've gotten one
legal threat from New York
whereas we you can't sue me compute Ella
to run this gallery space are generously
allowing us to be here for 3-4 months
this space isn't permanent but the
museum is permanent in downtown Helsinki
I'd say about a third of the stuff I
have on eBay the other third I've gotten
through special D forums some of them
have been donated which is great so I
won't just come by my office today I
want to give you this you know one of
them was a Palm Pilot I took it but I
can't put it on display because the Palm
Pilot was a success
two of these items I've bought in dark
alleys paying cash only can't tell you
which ones they are all of which leads
to one fairly obvious question what
happens if the museum of failure files
one serious concern that I do have is
when a product is overhyped and then
when it's launched it doesn't meet those
expectations then there's a big risk of
failure so i lying if I said I wasn't
nervous that the museum I fairly would
flop okay it would have to be on display
at its own museums mazuma traders like
is one of these perpetual everlasting
machines it can never it can never fail
thank you very much to Samuel Worcester
I'm all the team at the Museum of
phyleus pull down the description for a
link to find out more
out them